from the film's website the about
section it says that you went in 2008
personally to walk the camino at that
point did you know
you were planning to make a film where
were you at in your life
well i absolutely had no intentions of
making this film
when i walked it was really i was
i was in between jobs relationships and
homes
and in the let's say it was the fall of
and to be honest you know i had a couple
months i felt sorry for myself not
having those things and then one day it
just occurred to me
it's sort of out of the blue like i
should take advantage of not having
these things
you know all my stuff was in storage and
i was in between jobs and
um and so i it just dawned on me that i
should do the camino
it kind of was just like divine
inspiration i guess you could say i had
lived in spain for about six years
so i had always sort of known about the
camino
but it never occurred to me to do it
until that moment
and so then within a couple of months i
was on the camino and walking
and i was just walking for me i had been
engaged to be married and that wasn't
the right fit and so my life was just a
little bit
i wasn't sure where i was going and so i
ended up on the camino
and when people found out one man in
particular
when he found out i was a filmmaker he
said oh you should do a documentary on
the camino
and my answer was absolutely not under
no circumstances
i had independently produced and
directed a short documentary
about 15 years before and swore i would
never
ever do it again it was just so
challenging to raise all the money and
do
everything without the support of a
production company or tv station
but my other big hesitation was for me
the camino is so sacred and so magical
i was really scared i couldn't do it
justice and so i was really hesitant
and it wasn't until i got home and
probably a good
three four weeks after that um i
decided to do the film it was really
like that little voice that kept saying
you need to do this you really need to
make a documentary on it
and so finally i kind of succumbed and
six years later here we are
one of the subjects in your film tomas i
believe he says that the kamino changes
most people
who walk it did it change you and how
it definitely changed me i there's a
saying on the camino that your real
camino starts when you get home
and and i think that was definitely the
case for me
for me walking the camino was it's not
that it was easy
but compared to making a film or
distributing the film
it was way easier than those things and
ma the making of the film
was very uh analogous to the walking
i really needed to reach out and ask for
a lot of help and
i had so many people literally thousands
of people that helped me make this film
and that's very much like on the camino
most people really get a lot of help
they have
these wonderful kind hospitalers usually
they're wonderful and kind that is
and who help you along the way and
sometimes they'll
care for your blisters take an hour out
of their day just to tend to your feet
and expecting nothing in return so i had
a lot of that on my
journey in making the film as well and i
think in terms of
how i changed i think my big lesson
from the camino was really learning how
much i was capable of
i think before i wasn't really living up
to my potential i kind of was very
content with staying behind the scenes
and being a producer and
not necessarily um
supporting or believing in my own vision
and this was really a case of me
think saying this is something i believe
in this is important
and i'm going to go after it
you